Harrison
and thank you for the uh
type I'll start that again thank you for
the opportunity to provide further
debate and alternative discussion and
further the Democratic process via
public forum
I must say councils encouraging public
forum use is to be commended
I do hope you appreciate my detailed
support material as attached to the
agenda which I take as read
I um I'd just like to say from a recent
newspaper article I read
um it was a milestone day Looms
in Long running invercargill Museum Saga
and I think more likely a millstone day
creating tens of millions of additional
rate payers debt is more abandon than a
milestone
and then I see Council on Nigel Skelton
believes Tuesday learns there's a
watershed moment
through the kaggle which will
potentially provide those in the city
with a nearly Christmas present
I I think an even better watershed
moment and Christmas friend would be the
reopening of the existing Museum
Building without the millstone of a
multi-million dollar burden
I needed to read a comment to the
article
what a travesty
strengthen the pyramid that's all it
needs
Council seems hell being on wasting
money at the expense of the ratepayer
how often did Marty visit our now said
moth board Museum over the last 50 years
I wonder
it's been an influential part of my life
since I was a small child I must have
visited the museum hundred of times
since the 1960s
and I make this point to in counselors
any Representatives we already have a
museum building we simply need to reopen
the doors let the community who own the
building
enjoy and utilize it
invercargills a small City are currently
56 800 people we don't need to urgently
build a New Zealand and a new Museum
there are many other
priorities that will need funding going
forward
and that's important please pause the
museum the new Museum build
you're a nearly foreign Council
please say
bold and new leadership reopen our
existing Museum
the issues should not be about option A
or option b
and a push to Market and Rush two
multi-million dollar
options forward
without having private transparent
consultation with the community you will
not regain a much-needed Trust of the
community
there is actually no real need to rush
and create a new building a seismic
survey has another 12 years before it
has to be completed yet alone the actual
strengthening would
study has thousands of rescue buildings
to my knowledge none have ever fallen
down and heard anyone you alone killed
anybody thousands of people occupy them
day and night
if the big one is quite comes all risky
buildings will be affected regardless of
strengthening events
the estimated fertility risk fatality
risk in a building under 34 in years
was about one in forty thousand to a
hundred thousand as a friend simply said
to me yesterday
something reacting the existing museum
is not rocket science
the existing museums should be regarded
and treated as a tonga a Heritage just
like Anderson house in the Civic Theater
we need to curious our heritage
not continually demolish and rebuild
not to mention the environmental costs
are doing so
Council really needs to do much then in
the areas of climate litigation
adaptation and resilience the matter
really needs to be taken on board and
seen in meaningful actions lead by
example uttering the words climate
change occasionally here and there in
discussion does not cut the mustard
a climate change mitigation impact and
environmental footprint of everything
you consider needs to be carefully
investigated
we are living in a time of Rapid change
in the way we we approach and respond to
everything consider business as usual
without considering climate impact and
environment it's a thing of the past
I was actually going to speak by soon
but ironically that didn't happen and I
was going to speak by Zoom to cut my
footprint down my environmental
footprint
and thank you
okay thank you Mr Peterson is there any
questions from councilors
either in
thanks yeah no um
back in 2014-15 invercargill made in the
capital city council made the decision
to build a new airport and and I
remember during the debate uh during the
consultation people said nah just took
the old one now do you think that was a
good move that we this is my question
was it a good move to build the new
airport where
and the other option was to keep it keep
the old one going
that was the expenditure of 14 million
dollars back then it's a uh it probably
didn't make a lot of difference this
cost a lot of more money and I think um
we should be considering moving the
airport now it's in a very low lying
area
yeah I suppose there's an answer yep
thanks
okay any further questions from
counselors
yeah
thanks for the uh submission no can you
tell me what the qualifications are of
the reader that you've quoted
mate
um an environmentalist lifelong with an
interest in climate change no sorry not
you know the reader that you've quoted
and the submission that you've made to
assist oh I don't know because there was
a non-deployment the otago
probably a thousand times they're not as
structural or civil engineering no
do you know if they have any
qualifications in risk assessment
no okay thank you thank you any further
questions
sorry one more yes not do you think that
the opportunity for a new building might
create
um the chance to do a green design
I I yes I do and I actually mentioned
that in my um my comments
um and in fact I I made the point that
they're searching essential and that's
actually one of the reasons why I think
we need to be
um pie hoeing on what we're planning to
do
and so that we make sure we get there
right it needs to be open and
transparent Daryl Council of Ludlow what
I um was concerned about very much is
that there's no detail with this and
that's been handed out to the public I
don't know um what the design of the
building is all I know is the mayor
stood up with a piece of paper and waved
it around and said this is a new
building we're going to build and the
previous
um debate last year it was the same
thing it was just a concept picture
there's no details of what it's going to
be and that needs to be brought out in
the open public to be transparent so
that we know it's not greenwashed
okay
last question yet
um Mr Peterson
did you read the
emphasis reinvisiting documents for to
unawa which is what this is based on and
which we consulted against uh last year
no I don't think I was privileged to see
them oh
I'm surprised you didn't it was very
freely available because in the uh the
talk about the environmental impact of
the building of the materials of which
it was built of the way that the uh
lighting heating all those sorts of
things were considered was part of the
project and visiting and that was costed
on that basis so that's where the
um
whilst there's no design there was an
approximation of the foot front if you
were but you did not see that no I I
yeah I don't think that I saw it in uh I
I as I said I just don't think there's
been any public details of design but
you know
if I miss seeing it well um that was
unfortunate as somebody who went out
with the consultation document but I can
assure you that the public did see it
um but having said that of course not
everybody did and obviously you were one
of those thank you for that thank you
okay we might leave it there in in the
interest of time and move forward thank
you thank you oh okay we've um
we've confirmed the minutes of the
meeting so we'll move on to the next
part of the agenda which is the museum
acceleration report project 2025 so
Aaron's going to
talk to this paper first
Fiora
okay so as outlined in the paper the
long-term plans roadmap 2 renewal had a
agreed a project to be added around the
Redevelopment of the museum
as part of the long-term plan
deliberations
elected members ask staff to go away and
to do a revisioning process on the
museum building and consider a number of
questions including whether or not the
community would be better served by a
new Museum building as opposed to
redevelopmental strengthening of the
existing Museum
that revisioning and reimagining process
took place and those recommendations and
consultation went out through the annual
plan process this year for the 2022
Financial year and a decision was made
by Council to instead proceed with a new
Museum building in Queens Park with a
separate storage facility to be
constructed at Tisbury
the budget for that project was
approximately 65 million dollars part of
which was to be third party funded and
the timeline for delivering the project
was to be by mid-2027.
with the incoming Council the delivery
team within the project management
office have been asked whether or not we
could look at accelerating that project
to have a delivery timeline for the new
building to be constructed and up by 12
2025 that's the building itself fit out
an opening to come beyond that date the
project management team have gone away
and have considered two different paths
to achieving this plan a is a path that
retains the storage facility at Tisbury
and constructs a new Museum on the
existing pyramid site
Plan B proceeds with keeping the
existing pyramid and not proceeding with
Tisbury and building a new Museum
building adjacent to the existing
pyramid site
so the team have worked very hard
crunched the numbers and come back with
advice on whether or not we can achieve
that program I'll hand over to Lee to
talk through the idiosyncrasies of
achieving that
[Music]
we'll just pop on screen the two plans
we'll start off with plan a and we'll
work through them
but there we go it's probably reasonable
reasonably terrible to read up there but
I'll talk through it
so yeah so the task has been set can we
have the base building complete by 1225
what we did went back to our program and
we've
condensed it up as much as we reasonably
reason we can do a couple of things
we've been very very key to acknowledge
is obviously for plan a the tidsbury
storage facility is critical and it's
very very important to ensure the 1225
date is is met
along with that we've condensed a lot of
the design and review periods we've
taken some steps to accelerate all our
procurement processes and our
procurement review times
um we've been very very clear with
everybody that you know it's going to be
a bit of ax to the Grind to make sure we
do make these dates there is no not much
little room left in this program
we've moved the experience or the fill
out piece to a little bit later in the
program to allow us to concentrate on
the physical architectural build we've
made content uh note that we're probably
going to have to have a number of
special Council meetings rather than
waiting for the calendar Council and
committee meetings as a bit of a an Ask
through Council to make sure we keep to
keep the plan
the demolition of the current facility
is also key to obviously getting access
to understand geotechnical and ground
and that sort of information there for
that to ensure the design proceeds the
speed but overall when we when we when
we crunch the numbers we condense this
thing up as as much as you can possibly
condense it up but still stick to the
ethos of the original plan is we get an
outturned date of the 16th of December
2025
so with the powers of project management
and the tools available to us a good
headwind and a lot of my
um 1225 looks to be achievable through
plan A
thank you any
Christians councilor Scout have you got
any for them oh I'm not just in the
sense that we Workshop this years today
obviously and thank you Aaron and Lee
for the outstanding work that the team
and your team's done around and it's
been hugely due diligence to be fair
enormous amount of work's been done so
from my on my behalf thank you for that
work and his worships
um it's been staggering to be honest and
to to get the time frames to where
um is the desire
um from both the mere end council is I
believe
hugely gratifying so
um in the sense of plan a as we see it
as we discussed yesterday in depth and
plan B what plan a does do quite clearly
it solves two issues it protects our
heritage in the sense of our culture by
the by the building of the storage
facility obviously and it also
accelerates the process and how we can
get our project 1225 Air Museum built
for our public it's been a long time
obviously
um I don't use the word Christmas
present facetiously I just think we have
a fantastic opportunity uh moving
forward to give our community something
to look forward to which they've missed
they have totally missed there's no
question
um in my mind there's pressure with the
program but we're up for the pre-show
the team are up for the pressure without
any
shadow of a doubt so I um I just fully
recommend that we move to plan a through
YouTube
I think it's the best the wisest and the
most exciting the biggest risk we have
for your team in my opinion the biggest
risk we have is not taking this risk is
not taking this risk the risk we have is
very very minimalistic it is so small in
the sense of projects we've had before
that it is in my opinion
um
it is the right thing to do for our
community okay thank you Darren can we
hear about Plan B please yeah that'd be
great
again it's equally difficult to see on
screen so plan B we looked at if we kept
the current Museum as a medium to long
term solution for storage we abandoned
the tidsbury storage facility project
and that therefore we removed the
demolition as well out of the sequence
to see if that had any real positive
effects the only problem with this
particular plan is the alternative site
needs to go through a change of use
process
um which in its in effect can take six
to eight months so we've plugged that in
and that in that in essence actually
pushes the design another few other bits
and pieces a little bit later and the
outturn of that takes us into April 2026
there is there is some uh question over
the uh change of use if we do get
challenged to the change of use we we
could impact the delay or delay the um
base build even further so that's the
that's the main difference between a and
b and it's just the introduction of that
change of use for the land
okay
thank you
yeah League just regarding the
acceleration risk table I just want to
um
for the tendering uh acceleration both
for the design team and Main build
contractor
it refers to Marcus a market analysis
uh have we done a report that highlights
these particular projects that are going
to be happening in the south island that
will be competing for horsepower and
this and this sort of construction field
and we we got a report that we can see
that
shows all these other other
buildings happening in the South Island
we haven't done a report per se because
these things move around quite a bit so
if we wrote a report six months ago
they'd be in a different position right
now to be firm you'd be writing a report
over and over
it's a good point we did we did do a
brief market analysis that that did have
a report when we first established the
project management office but to Lee's
Point um with the current market as
hyperinflated as it is um things have
just changed very quickly beyond that
market analysis so really it's a matter
of us getting out there having lots of
conversations and testing the view of
who would actually be interested in in
partnering with us on any of the
projects we're wanting to take forward
okay that's with the construction
companies and and designers but
obviously these the question I'm asking
about is these contracts these builds
that are already
um that have been signified that are
going to happen I thought there may have
been a sort of an in-house report I
think we just keep a constant watch on
you know progresses of selects of you
know um whether the hydrogen thing is
going to take off whether you know when
the data grid
um facility is going to take off we're
having you know constant sort of
feedback from some of the larger
contractors who are looking at these
particular projects like Canadian
hospital is another one just keeping a
close eye on that okay so what I'm
trying to do is just put that particular
risk which we will be later on adopting
as one of the recommendations putting it
in perspective yeah so there is there is
no report as such no it's because the
Market's so fluent okay that's fine
foreign
I guess this is a question to Lee but it
seemed to me that the option A is a very
good example of value engineering and
Expediting of the previous plan
um and therefore you know something we
may have arrived at in any case well if
we just you know as we were working
through this
um would that be a reasonable way to to
describe plenty yeah kaplani is not far
off our original methodology it's just
like condensed to a point where you know
we're just trying to hit that 12 25 date
you know could that be achieved we've
figured out that it's highly likely it
can be achieved we just got to make sure
we put the skinny on everything okay and
the second
um
question
which really goes to plan B
um
and yesterday several and this kind of
goes to North Point too
um several of the councilors went to the
pyramid
and we had the opportunity to get right
up to the top and to talk to Aaron and
Lee
um about particularly about fire risk in
the earthquake risk India
um I had previously been probably been
supportive of Plan B but what became
apparent I think in that conversation is
that even if the pyramid had been chosen
as the storage site if we chose Plan B
then it could not be a long-term
solution we would have had to move the
the collection at some point in a not
too distant future because it's a fire
risk so I I think would seem to be an
obvious option
um as knaul had pointed out in others of
let's continue to use pyramid uh uh I
think that was probably
um
unsafe in the long term so I I put it as
a question leave it at me you view two
yeah the the the museum the current
Museum building doesn't meet the needs
and you're just kick in a problem
further down the road
um abandoned in tesbury is abandoning an
opportunity to be fair
thank you okay thank you okay so we've
got
um some recommendations in front of us
and we'll need to move it in a secondary
for that so thank you Leslie and
Darren thank you so um do you do you
want me to um particularly detail the
movement I'm doing for four in five
so it would be for
a and b one
and five a
yes yeah we do is there any
it looks just uh I wasn't sure when I
was going to bring this up but as an
addition
um what I feel is that we should also at
the same time as this look for changing
the
um the classification of the remaining
half of the tennis courts at the same
time so we'll just can I just stop you
there because I think we've got an
amendment to the gun Amendment emotions
here okay cool that's right so we have
the motion we've got to move in second
in so so just for one to six that's for
one to such a citizen I think there's an
amendment to one of the Motions Justin
and through YouTube Justin in
recommendation three where it goes down
to four I'd add a fifth one in there
that's it would ask the chief executive
provide a report on the reclassification
of the remaining tennis courts and the
building attest
um which are west of the existing
pyramid building Zone and has Reserve
status and the rationale for that is it
gives us some potential options in the
future so it doesn't hold up Project A
or B but what it does is it allows us to
consider other options for that piece of
land in the future so it would be a
parallel process
but I'd like to get a report from the
chief executor that gives us some advice
on that
so does that cover what you were
thinking yeah because obviously the
report would then become action or not
yeah yes so we might just get that
Amendment
Mr chair can I just suggest that
since three is actually noting the
background
it's probably not the place to put it
the amendment should be in your
Amendment yeah
it could be a seven
yes rather than trying to amend three
yes yes
so we will put that in a 0.7 yes thank
you for pointing that out
but
yes I wouldn't would uh we need to move
in a second to accept the the amendment
and Tom
foreign
information
please
yeah yeah
okay so we'll put that motion to the
um
committee so all those in favor of the
motion sorry just clarify chair we're
just putting the amendment yes the
amendment the amendment sorry yes 0.7 to
the to the meeting all those in favor
against carried
okay so now we will put through the
motion with respect to
um
six
one
um
in with each of the individual
subcourses available so if whole order
does
yeah
it is yeah so about and read the ones
we're approving so it's
playing I and then what's recommendation
four that's a then do you want to keep
coming down
yeah
and the
answers
I mean six and there's a one and seven
we need to
no let's go one and six five six one and
seven let's say and six isn't it
accelerate Department
what's all of those things
four days and six
okay so we have the approvals on the
screen which is the highlighted
ones and read from the
sub courses so just bring it down
that's right so it's
um
we're approving six and then we're
approving
or
one B one five eight
and then all of six and then the new
one being seven
yeah
everyone's clear on what we're approving
and you would need to remove from 4B the
word either
is to be achieved through yes thank you
so we've got that episode draw
anyway
but I clarified the vote cheers on all
seven items yes it is thank you
good to go okay oh cool all those
before you put the motion the Mover and
the second to do you have a a right to
say something about the okay in your
lockdown reason yeah I think it probably
that's probably appropriate because as
has been pointed out it is a milestone
decision we're taking it as one of the
one of the definitely identified top
priorities for this Council to deliver
this Museum uh project 1225 is a
significant acceleration
and we have had two options to consider
and as the Mover of the motion I just
want to say that my moving of option a
um is based on the fact that very
careful reading that I think we've all
done as counselors
um has certainly led me to the belief
that option A is the superior
option that will deliver us exactly what
we had undertaken to deliver is the best
outcome for air
a rum
invercargill city
um option b on the other hand I would
describe as the as the nervous Nelly
option
um it is far more high risk as an option
it has far more risk that is
unacceptable when both lengthening the
time frame which I think we are all
committed to shortening rather than
lengthening and also leading to some
operational costs that we would very
much wish to avoid that is if we did go
for option b and leave the existing
Museum in place to actually pick the
existing museum open and in use as a
storage facility would be unacceptably
high operational costs that went on for
a number of years certainly not a legacy
that we want to leave for the people of
invercargill
um so on that basis
option b would be a much inferior
outcome option A is what this Council
has long committed to achieve it has
been a great
um pity for all of us that has taken as
many years as it has to come to this
report this point where we actually have
a proposal hopefully that we can all
agree on but that is my reasoning to to
move forward with the picture name thank
you for talking and yeah thank you chair
uh my what a journey this has been
um I guess I was initially a bit
cautious about some of the imaginations
that went through the Electoral period
but councilor Scout and to where project
staff and to Aaron I think they've come
together and worked very hard to come up
with a project that
that meets ultimately what it is that
we've all had a lot of feedback that
people want and that is the facility
open again yes some people want the
current facility open just throw the
doors open it's just not something that
we're able to do with the risk profile
of the building and the legislation as
it as it stands
um I was initially worried that
um if we abandoned the Tisbury storage
site that would create issues because
ultimately this whole project started
because of the fire risk in in the
current building and and the risk of
that pose to the collection inside
um then there came the whole amount of
space for storage and exhibition so
ultimately we've arrived in a space in
my it's been awake getting there
where I think we're on the cusp of
getting something really good as swiftly
as we possibly can not withstanding the
fact that we know that there are risks
around that
um and we made very similar decisions
around them to Cargo Central limited as
well knowing that there were risks and
and some of them have eventuated but
they're still pretty much to time and
we hope having gone through two
lockdowns at another Global pandemic
isn't something that that steps in and
the international markets settle down so
um I'm really uh pleased to see the work
that's gone on and I commend those that
have been involved for it as someone
who's
been a part of trying to get something
done for a long time pretty happy to uh
second this motion
thank you is there any others that wish
to speak to
Yemen yeah thank you just a couple of
things which might help
um public understand what the position
we've come to in recommendation 3b3
we've got a mention that the Tuatara is
going to a purpose-built
facility in the center of Queen's Park I
just want to be clear for the public
that the councilors also want a presence
of the Tuatara and the new Museum as
well
that doesn't mean they're all there but
uh Henry and some of his covers should
be there because that's a big draw card
for us
on the issue of the um recommendation 6B
it talks about risk and some of my other
colleagues have talked about this as
well but look there's also some very
positive things within the risk as well
so bringing it 40 year or 18 months or
whatever it ends up being saves us about
10 cost per year I mean that's that's
what the marketplace is moving up and so
uh simple math that we get it done a
year earlier then we save ourselves five
six million dollars potentially
um and the last thing I think is the
issue that Noel writes when he was
talking earlier on is something I'd like
us to consider going forward is whether
we can have a very eco-friendly or a
green or a carbon neutral type Museum
which could be constructed of water as
opposed to uh
um traditional concrete and buildings uh
it could be
um world leading if we went down that
track I understand that the costs of
wood as opposed to steel and concrete is
about comparable so given the backdrop
of the park and the potential stream in
the front it could be quite a nice
environment so I think that would be
something for us to consider I think
it's you okay
all right excellent so on behalf of the
talker that are going to be housed and
the purpose built and designed storage
facility I thank you very much like
Darren I'm I carried with me 30
something years worth of conversations
that ewe have had about
the conditions that our Taco was stored
in
and
um
air aspirations for their safety it's
been very much on my mind in the last
while and the idea that
we continued
to house them so
um
unsafely
has caused me quite some concern so I
want to congratulate the team for coming
to this place because I think that
I don't
believe in given the conversation with
Mr Peterson earlier that people have
taken very seriously the concerns that
we have raised about the risks involved
with the current building and
um I'm delighted to see that Within
These recommendations all those concerns
have been acknowledged and addressed and
that
their option b
um
was
considered to be too risky on that basis
their option I would do better job
I think we've moved a long way in terms
of what we know about
what is good storage for Tonga
whether it be paper-based or wooden
based or
anything else but also in terms of
long-term term storage and
research and the opportunity for us to
actually become quite leading in
Southland in that respect so I
congratulate everybody who has come to
this place and I pray for a fair wind
to push 12 25 as possible
okay so you're in just what I'd like to
make a comment to to the um
Mia in the council is in also the staff
have put a lot of work into this over
the last sort of months to get to where
we are
um it's significant and we appreciate it
on the behalf of the community so thank
you
right oh we've got to move in a second
or so we will put that to the vote
all those in favor of the Motions as
they are on the screen
all right all right in your post
carried
hold on
okay so next item on the agenda is the
um city streets stage one cost type
update so
welcome Ian again you'll you'll speak to
this
Russell okay thank you
good afternoon good afternoon councilors
and um
thank you for the opportunity to update
the committee
um this is a project for the city street
stage one which is done on East Street
is a significant and um somewhat complex
at times project but it's a pretty
important project for the city center
and we're about 70 percent uh through
that and I have to say it is still
pretty great I guess to hit summer
months and for people to be out there
and actually uh start to
start to use our city street scopes
um we've got about four months to finish
the project which has has taken about 19
months
we have a number of recommendations in
the report
and we do continue to monitor the costs
of these Pro this project as it is
developing but we are projecting a cost
of about 10 over the current budget
and some of the key issues that we've
struck
um obviously inflation and covert have
been things that have caused quite a bit
of disruption to our project
we've certainly
um learned quite a bit about what's um
under the ground and we've had to work
alongside a number of construction other
sites when I was going to say we've had
to work with
under over and beside some of those
other contractors as they've done their
works as well
and we have found um I guess quite a bit
of contamination and archaeological type
binds
um but as I said our project just
projecting
um the cost of the project to be
approximately 10 of our functions
thank you questions
in
um yeah Russell um stage two is going to
be coming in front of council for a bit
of scrutiny and the future of it what do
we need to revise the current budget
that we have for stage two of 14 million
dollars knowing what the experience
we've gained from stage one because
obviously we're going to be debating the
future of stage two we'll need some
solid figures of what we're dealing with
thank you
I'm happy to take that question
um look I think definitely everybody
acknowledges that there's been some
learnings through stage one of the
project uh it's a project probably
unlike any of us have undertaken before
um I think it's fair to say that uh don
Street has probably gone closer to what
we would have expected than esk Street
has
primarily because we haven't had as much
of the interface with the other
developments issue there
we'd expect stage two on Kelvin Street
in particular to be more like Don Street
than like esk Street in terms of not
having those interfaces so definitely
there'd be some learnings around what
products we wouldn't want to wouldn't
use in terms of efficiencies but I think
the key pieces that we we wouldn't have
that multi-development facade that we
were trying to bring together on stage
age two so I would expect it to be a
simpler project to deliver
and so that would mean that the budget
would stay about as that that's right we
wouldn't be looking to increase the
budget for stage two if that project
proceeds thanks
okay any other
important questions
okay so we need a
um
someone to move the motion in terms of
accepting the recommendations
and thank you Ian
all those in
favored okay
um automate project management office
status report
login
thank you chair
for the project management office report
the program report
the first uh the first Camp of rank is
city streets stage one obviously my
colleagues just talked to you about that
so I won't add too much more to that
other than that we are keeping a very
very close eye on it and there's going
to be a lot of lessons learned that'll
come out of stage one before we get to
provide on the road with with uh stage
one solution should I say rather than
before we proceed with stage two
the stead Street Stock Bank has
proceeded uh well we're just about in
the planning phase now putting up the um
cultural artwork so that's going to look
fantastic for the city as we get through
uh next month might not be 100 finished
before Christmas we might have to do a
little bit pieces to finish it off in
January but it's going to look
absolutely stunning that that project
has gone uh Gone very well for us to
bring some water main I put most people
using the North Road to be glad that
we're through there now
um the two main drill shots have also
been completed they were probably the
highest risk elements of that project so
they're now behind us so that project is
really really trekking very well
I'm pleased to say that the media tower
has also been strengthened to above
earthquake prone status so we're just
waiting for some paperwork and we can
get the earthquake prone status removed
from the media tower at rugby park so
that's gone very well for us and we're
planning stage two for the strengthening
your rugby park
this building's been a bit of a bit of a
challenge uh the first phase of that
project has been completed and we're
just preparing reports to come back
through to elt and then through the
Council on that but uh that's been a a
bit of a challenge for sure
um obviously the museum development
we've talked a bit about that already so
that's uh well documented
um obviously with the plan a uh being
talked about today we have that um the
kids we design in with building consent
at the moment
so um great great to hear that plan a is
um favored and that's that overall that
project is running on time and on budget
pleased to say the bluff boat ramps had
a bit of a turnaround and we're
proceeding quite well with that and we
just got the concepts went to the
community board a couple of months ago
and we're just waiting for some fees and
estimates from our designers so we can
proceed with that we hope to have some
pontoons and Jetties in the water next
year uh a great a great uh milestone for
Bluff
and the housing and Innovation project
is taken away quite well we've had the
um some early Qs estimates they're a
little bit higher than we wanted it to
be
um not that we have too much of a
concern for it at the moment we believe
that we'll definitely
um bring that back on track so overall
the program is looking in in good shape
to be fair
okay questions
uh this this may not be one and for your
department lay but they're both Bluff
boat ramp when it is up and running
is there a plan on obviously recouping
uh user charges or something like that
but it's not my department no it's not
your department but I thought I'd take
the opportunity I believe it has been
looked at before user pays and various
other schemes but that that is something
those are work stream we are working I
see Steve grabbing a microphone yeah
yeah stay Theory Mr cheers
yes counselor that's the plan is that
within the original budget we had an
allocation of funds for this project
that was uh to be paid back through the
user fees that would be gathered from
the users of the new boat rep cool
thanks now let's answer them thanks
thank you and I have a question uh
no
um just with respect to the boat Rim
also are we communicating with the bluff
Community around that time frame for
delivery so that's clear to them not
just the board but the water Bluff
Community yeah so we've done um a number
of uh comms and media things and we've
also actually just started
um a brand new project control group
which actually has members of the
community on the actual control group so
there was something we identified when
we did workshops with the community
we've actually brought them in actually
to the project team delivering it yeah
because I mean you'll be aware the bluff
Community see that as a very big piece
of the puzzle they need to sold for them
yeah so
yeah that's good
I'm like
um I'm really concerned
I'm scheduled slightly
have we got a Target you know this is
something that Erie supported during the
um
the fund around us yeah or earlier this
year so could you give us some sort of
indication of how
how much delay there is in there we're
probably about three months behind from
where we wanted to be
um we're still our targeting consent or
consent application this year so next
month we hope to put in the uh building
consent application which is about two
and a half months behind where we
originally planned that means we're
going to be looking at a contractor
um early second quarter which again is a
few months behind where we wanted to be
but we would be having contractors in on
on ground by mid next year
actually Evelyn asked the question I was
going to ask so okay
um yes sorry sorry you mean for YouTube
um Lee just a couple of three issues
um I don't see the bluff Hill upgrade
anywhere where we've got the government
funding nearly a million dollars that's
it not in my program
um
Steve
yeah three years to cheer
um I think like the program's being run
through the Parks and Recreation team
and we're managing that project within
that group we can bring a report back on
progress to the community wellbeing
committee yeah that'd be good
um yeah the other issue Lee is one that
I raised back before the election of the
estimate to complete on the cab
refurbishment project which was
initially sitting at 26 and was now
sitting at 16. so my question was really
probably for Michael that when we did
the long-term plan financing did we
Factor the 26 and to our thinking going
forward
uh three self-chair the 26 has not been
included in our forecasting in relation
to plans it's always been based off the
16 budget that was approved by Council
so obviously a second question to that
then why did we have a figure sitting in
there in the August
report to we're just going to show us
that with 10 million dollars higher than
it so we when we went through the early
stages of this
um project yeah we had a Qs estimate to
do a full refurb of the building
the maximum we could potentially spend
all bells and whistles of 26 million
dollars so we ended up we had amended
the estimate to complete the 26 million
to give Council oversight but that could
be what you could potentially spend if
you went
um all the way with all the way with
that project
thank you
okay any further questions or comments
right
okay so that
uh project office report has been moving
second so we'll put that to the
oh sorry we haven't uh can we have a
move
uh Tom yep thank you all those in favor
aye against Jared
right the next item number nine 2022
2023 quarter one performance report
foreign
so this report provides you an overview
of performance for the first quarter of
22 23.
um I won't go over the matters that Lee
has just reported on in his pmo report
but you'll see there we have a Graphic
that provides for the public a view of
delivery against the roadmap
um I think the key highlight messages
that you might want to take away in
terms of service level performance is
really the good news around the uptick
and visitors and user numbers right
across
um council's public facing operations
this is really a turnaround from the
previous quarter so that's good to see
um there are currently 68 of 99
performance measures are currently on
target which is pretty much
um
level was where we were studying this
time last year there are six that are
confirmed as not met for the year those
are all Dia set targets mostly in the
regulatory area where if you miss one
performance then you miss the whole year
um
so I'll pass on to Patricia to talk
about financial performance
thank you
in relation to financial performance the
first quarter we are slightly better
than what um we're forecast to be but it
is still early days
um within the financial year I'm not
getting I'm not got a huge grin yet
um
there are some things that are still not
quite sitting right within the plan so
there is some forecast changes that
we're asking Council to make budgets
predominantly the biggest one being
depreciation which is a result of the
asset revaluation at City June head
appreciation has gone up by eight
million dollars for the year so we're
seeking that forecast change so that we
can have an amended budget to be working
towards
and
from a capital delivery it's pretty much
on the numbers within the performance
reports show the full Capital program
not just
um Lee's strategic projects so it shows
the full Capital program so we're at a
14
of the forecast spent the first quarter
which we'd expected that to be slow to
start off with and we ramp up as we go
through the year
so that's still expected to be on
delivery at present
just any questions
yes yeah Patricia this is the forecast
change around the depreciation of eight
million dollars so that's uh that's an
ongoing thing isn't it
so that we could find eight million
dollars somewhere along the line
um I guess it's just want to confirm
that it's based on 100 depreciation the
bits the hunt that's the for the
accounting entry for the depreciation we
have not funded that full amount of
depreciation so we are left with some
unfunded depreciation from a rates
funding perspective okay so going
forward we still have some levers that
we can pull yes thank you
listen happy to move one to six Mr chair
and and just to say that the um forecast
change has outlined are all
very well explained and sensible at this
point in the financial cycle
thank you okay we've got a mover for
that
to accept the
recommendations
okay all those in favor
aye aye against right that's carrot
it's item ten one inch short update
Patricia stank
so this is a um report that just gives
some high level
Financial comments
um there are some aspects that many may
have seen previously at Insurance
meetings some of those will come to both
because there's a risk aspect and a
financial aspect
so if I go through the um High the high
level issues in relation to debt so at
the end of the quarter we had 101
million
um of borrowings and cash and cash
Investments of 58 million so that gave
us a net deposition of 42 or 43 million
um a weighted average costed it so our
average interest rate on that was only
2.51 we are expecting that to increase
sharply we're having some we've had
after the end of the quarter 20 million
debt roll off and 10 million had to be
refinanced which was at a much higher
rate
um it was one of a higher ones so we're
expecting that to increase over the
coming
period
um the line to ICL
is currently sitting at the start of
November at 18.95 that has increased in
the last week
bye apology that don't have that number
on me but it has go has gone up so it's
still below the maximum of 31.45 million
um and just a reminder that a counselors
that
there is a risk should that first amount
not be repaid come December next year
from a credit rating
um perspective you've been advised and
it's been in the paper we've retained
our fetch double A Plus stable Outlook
so that gives us some Surety going
forward and their cash and cash
Investments and borrowings are all
within the tolerance that we'd like at
the moment
from a management perspective
um
we are watching those and we continue to
watch our debts um
the rates figures are pretty much
similar to what we would say year on
year
um
and it doesn't impact it for when we put
penalties on so we'll have a better feel
after this last quarter
after this Friday when we see what's
what remains outstanding
I've also provided some expense analysis
so that you've got some greater details
of what was sitting in there
um employee expenses and other expenses
line
within the profit and loss account that
was within the quarterly report and some
more variances there about why things
are
um well we've got significant variances
today and employees
and some within the other expenses as
well
if there's any questions
yeah I've got a couple
with respect to the Ico loan how often
are we meeting with them to understand
their ability to repay in terms of what
they've committed to under the loan
agreement
we are in regular discussions with them
okay and so the current indications are
that they can and will be able to repay
that or the indications that the last um
update that we've provided was that we
where they will be able to pay a portion
of it on time
did they give any occasion of how much
that portion would be we haven't had the
latest one I don't think it'd be Andrew
so when would we expect to get a another
update which what didn't afford the
actual numbers
I I think the uh sorry through or to use
the chair
um the there'll be an update on that
when the Holden company presents uh the
council this stage forecast around the
first uh December because uh the holding
company has a better is managing that
investment all but not the loan directly
on your behalf so we've got to do an
update then if that's suitable so first
of December yep yep okay thank you
foreign
just another question around the right
so just to make sure I've got my heat
around this so on page 109 so from
August 22
rates always will Circle 1.7 million and
now that's dropped down to
just over a million
and we're reading that right or we
haven't got 1.7 in a minute here we are
so total 2.7 no no
yeah it's decreased so we are getting
people we are collecting those we are
collecting them yeah and is there any
been any analysis around
the reason
for those arrays
is there Gene is there any theme or
not noticeable at the moment okay but we
will expect to see that coming forward
there's a number of people who
have chosen not to pay rates okay have
advised us that they will not be paying
rates yeah and we have recourse for the
banks and mortgages don't we so the
recourse for the banks and mortgages and
our ultimate recourses to sell property
yeah but the first recourse is usually
to the banks which will pay the rates
and then take that up so we make it the
bank's problem yes
are we investigating those options we
there's a standard process for us to do
okay
okay after what 90 days
uh tends to be done
because they can pay right through but
right so it's not yeah so if they miss a
payment they still get a through well
okay
okay thank you
Tom
I notice in the um the net the breakdown
page
um the the latest lgfe interest group
4.06 percent
uh maturity in May 28th can you just
speak to the benefit that we are seeing
compared to from lgfe compared to what
we could get in open market
don't have it exactly the head but it is
that sort of borrowing would probably be
well over five at the moment I would be
what I think would be closer to five
percent I haven't actually had to look
to see what it is so we're still we
still are seeing it it's the lgfa still
is the cheapest source of funds for us
at the moment and currently that is our
only borrowing Source we only we're
borrowing through that we have a standby
facility with a retail bank but that is
a term for our okay thank you okay
any further questions or comments
easily but thanks Mr chair look it's a
comment and I've said it before but I
just think it does have to be
acknowledged in the in the committee
meeting that the AAA Plus rating news is
is excellent and all compliments to it
to our staff who who are once again
um been a big part of the delivery of it
and I also just want to refer to The
Bancorp remark
um on page 120 that icc's cost of funds
is one of the very lowest in the
government local government sector that
ban Corp is aware of
I just think that does actually need to
be recorded because it does say
something about the actual prudent
management that air
um staff have for many years displayed
and what has been happening so you
really just wanted to record those
things because I think it's important
that that is acknowledged those are
pretty significant outcomes yes yeah I'd
endorse that particularly around the
credit rating that's
very good time to have a very good
credit running
okay
um
foreign
someone to move that we accept the
recommendations on point 10 being the
financial update thanks Alan and second
to Barry thank you all those in favor
aye aye against carried
right
okay so we need now to move to
um
the public excluded portion of the
agenda so
um need a mover and a second to move us
a lot thanks Tom and second uh thanks
Lisa
all those in favor hi Jared thank you
sorry carried